[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
if i'm on an elevator and anyone
over the age of 60 walks onto the
elevator i'll hold your breath
no i'll get off the elevator period
anytime
every time why because especially if i'm
alone in the elevator
because if this person dies i'll
probably just leave
yeah you know what i mean and because i
don't want to i don't know how to call
and i don't know what
who to call i don't know what papers to
sign
i don't know who to interview i got [ __ ]
to do you don't you don't have to do
almost any of that
if you died in an elevator and you're
just by yourself where you have you
can't just leave
you would just go somebody died in there
and then they show up and then the
paramedics help them okay so
let's get this let's play this out okay
all right
i'm in an elevator yeah old man walks in
the old man and he goes tell all young
man
i was in the korean war because all
people always say something like that
or they all say you know i love that
chinese restaurant down the street
and i'll be like oh okay cool
[Music]
my heart
[Music]
is this the hospital i don't know what
to call is this hospital
well you got to call 9-1-1 oh [ __ ] that
9-1-1
9-1-1 yes um an old man died
what's the address i don't know
i'll be right back and i can run outside
i gotta look at the address it's
five five four four three
what street sure what street are we on
did that
tamberla tamberlin what state
california it's california oh [ __ ]
california
camberlin 995543 california tamberlin
okay well then um the ambassador will be
there as soon as possible
can i leave no you have to go back in
with the man go in right now oh [ __ ] as
i run back in
oh [ __ ] okay i gotta do something i
gotta put my mouth in his mouth
to go back outside i'll probably have a
cigarette itch
not by this time though oh yeah yeah
yeah
sir yeah yeah were you the man that
called the police i am the one that i
know okay
what happened to the man where is he
he's in the elevator come with us right
now come with us right now come with us
right now
get with me right now come on let's go
oh [ __ ] is that him right there of
course no there's another dead
guy around the block sir i don't need
your attitude i'm just trying to find
out how this man died when he died did
you make him [ __ ] or poop did you make
him
cause i didn't i don't know what to do
so i just punched his chest so you
caused this man to throw up and have
diary inside of this elevator well
because i put my mouth on his mouth
turn around sir you're under arrest turn
around you're under arrest what the [ __ ]
i have an idea you're on the road
why do all japanese commercials they
jump and they soar and
why because they're so happy when they
take the product because it's like
chocolate yeah why do white people in
like
diet coke commercials or whatever they
take a sip and they just turn
we go we go like this yeah
yeah yeah i hate that because
because i don't buy the product when
you're like that well but you don't
support whites in general
i [ __ ] you i'm mr white i love white
people what do you think's more white
i've
eat i've eaten i've sucked at white
penises yeah you have such a couple of
ways yeah yeah and vaginas have you ever
sucked black dicks
never just whites yeah okay cool maybe
you do like whites
oh i'm sure you're so offended that you
look like a squash
there isn't a person watching this that
hasn't said squash
not one not one person that hasn't said
squash
that doesn't bother you look at that
picture behind you it looks like you're
growing from a gourd
like i think that the n word
which word the n word nice no no
no nintendo nintendo no um the n-word
you know friends black friends talk to
each other
right they say the end they go what's up
my nintendo right hey what's up nintendo
and they're like what's up right right
right
but then there are other such situations
where they go
let's hang that nintendo
let's hang that nintendo what why bill
why bill cause he's a nintendo you
fixing to hang in a nintendo yeah he's a
porch nintendo
did you see what happened what happened
we turned our back for 10 minutes and
done nintendo's movie
yeah you know what we got to do what we
got to do hang them in the motherboard
i'm kicking out them
i'll go over to that nintendo's house
right now yeah i'll tell them listen
here
i'll tell you how we catch them we take
a bunch of bananas
and some crack right
you know what i meant crack crack dipped
in watermelon juice
[Laughter]
is that out by the way these are good to
cut that out no these are just
characters these are characters and
we're doing something
is that is that gonna get cut out of the
podcast i'll leave that in
and i'll make it up i don't even know if
this is a game but you you say you tell
me one
sentence of a story right one sentence
i'll do the second sentence and we'll
just keep going jules you have to oh
that is the game
yeah you do one word word one word
everyone says one word that is that what
is that the sentence
you say one word and then you try and
keep the cadence of an actual story yeah
yeah
you want to try that a phrase or a word
let's do the phrase one word i mean
let's do a word okay just a word yeah so
jules you're playing number one
and number two this is how it works no
this
is how you
works
we'll be right back yeah but that's
exactly how it is you you everyone says
you know what i mean you're supposed to
say it
but it's fine all right jules do you not
want to try it jules
i'm i'm ready to go all right once there
was
a pumpkin gourd in connecticut
and it went what did she say went
yeah this isn't going to work get closer
to the next speaking yeah you have to
get closer to the mic
also we can't you can't like take time
it has to be
yeah no one could take time i didn't
yeah she's got to speak up
she's going to have to speak up and
louder put them back
i'm sorry i i vowed never to say that
again
[ __ ] mike to the mouth okay all right
don't get angry
all right ready okay so once
there was a woman named chlorine
and she swam very well
but one time there was this
huge pumpkin
[Laughter]
all right
all right you know the last one we did
no no it's fine it's our first improv
game
the last one we did we brought up the
pumpkin and and i'm just saying
there's just so many you know nouns that
you could you could appear
right anything anything right anything
ever on
the earth you know i mean whatever and
you chose pumpkin
all right so let's start over right and
not use
we're starting complete so this time
don't use previous words
so that you can you know okay why don't
we bobby i have a question
yeah how about the three of us try to
explain this to her real quick by using
the game
okay oh yeah why don't we do that yeah
okay first you
have to talk directly in to
the microphone then you must explain to
the audience that we are not
that smart
i really like this podcast so um what's
up one last one
just yeah let's do it doesn't get
giggles but i want i want rudy to start
it so yeah
rudy okay one
time i ate uh pumpkin
you know if i was in the japanese
internment camps and you were like
an american soldier you wouldn't slide
bread underneath the fence to feed me
you don't think i would help you out i
don't think you would
in fact i'll tell you why why because
even coming to this [ __ ] location
yeah there was so much deception going
on do you think that was do you think i
was trying to like
trick you on how to get here well this
guy ari manas that you're sidekick
he's not my psychic he's my he's my he's
your sidekick he's my assistant he's
your robin
he's not really my robin he's like my
little assistant oh you're a little
assistant he's like my little tiny boy
this [ __ ] guy no get back up dude i'm
start okay you know what dude
if he pops in again dude i will leave
and i'm telling i
if you don't if you don't think that i'm
gonna go through with that you're i got
another thing coming
do you think in a fist fight you could
beat him i don't care
i dare you to come in again don't
interrupt this ari
hey what'd you say let's start over man
my energy you're fine let's talk about
the internment camps this is where
all the juice is for me all right okay
if you were in the camps you think i
wouldn't help you out
i would definitely i'd be like um hi
when are we leaving
when do we get released and i go listen
i i talk to everybody
we're gonna save a few but you don't
seem nimble enough to get away
yeah but i know how to like crawl i know
but you just seem there's so much
mass you're just so you're saying i'm
fat no no just round ah
and i can't we can't roll you out of
here yeah
but all i'm asking for is some bread i
know and you've asked for bread every
day
so many days in a row that this is an
issue for us yeah so i have to stop
eating the bread we can get you out of
here
okay so let me ask you a question sure
we get no food
yeah i would love to give you no food no
but you have that you've been doing it
no i've been we've been giving you a
little bit of food you've been eating
other people's food
oh that's right that's right you keep
eating other soldiers or other captives
food
right so if you stop eating for say like
an hour and a half we can get you right
out of here
how about like a tempura shrimp roll or
something
can you make one of those no why
because we don't have any of the
equipment oh okay but listen we'll get
you out
you know we don't have noodles here oh i
know how you guys like noodles i love
udon you guys being you
yeah guys how about one of those like
beverages where it's look at the ramekin
yeah you pop at your pocket what is that
called you should know what that's
called i don't know
is boba what's boba tapioca balls
which was my nickname in high school
tapioca balsa yeah wait a minute
a national address right now you're
you're the president united states oh
god not this yes we're gonna do it
you're gonna look right into your camera
right there
no no this one right here right that one
straight ahead which one right here i
want you to make a national address
to the country to tell them that we're
i'm not going to be funny about it
though i want to be real
yeah of course that's what they need out
here you're the president a lot of times
when i do these improvs
i i lean toward funny don't be funny i
want to be real
this is real all right okay so i want to
do not laugh i'm not gonna
because it's not funny tell her she's
the one that does it all right i want
you to address the nation and tell them
that we're
what's going on though tell me this
scenario can i tell you yeah we're under
attack right now we've had a terrorist
attack
okay okay all right where in in new york
city in the subway line
okay but can i tell you what was going
on down there what a bunch of terrorists
decided to start raping uh okay
that's all you need to know raping and
killing people in the subway you're my
secretary of defense
in the subway this is what this is
what's going to go on backstage by the
way you're my secretary of defense
sure okay sir i got it okay so you need
to address the country i got it
in three terrorists two
to the people jamie i your president
have a national address for you okay
as we know our constitution creates a
foundation for
in which we must react to global
epidemics and also national ones
and something horrific occurred
in new york city um
i also want to add that um i
as presidents to the people right
based on all the amendments especially
the second one
and all of them they're all important by
the way
the amendments were created right as
you know a tool set in which we can look
down
the line we have
we have 50 plus amendments there are a
lot
there are a lot all right tell them we
will we'll get to that because
i know that i have to fill 30 minutes
right they want to know what happened
tell them what happened sir
sir i'm sorry some people are dying
this is no laughing matter
i apologize this is no laughing matter
right
yesterday last night last night last
night at two in the morning
so technically today
so technically they technically didn't
right
although some would assume that it
happened yesterday
because it happened in the wee hours
[Laughter]
yesterday at two in the morning in the
subways of our great city of new york
which is a part of the united states of
america
i'm sorry i don't know why i'm sorry
what happened sir
a gig of terrorists isis aka al-qaeda
[Laughter]
aka you know from turkey
assange okay hassan his wife okay asan
and his wife
right they dispatched their cronies aka
the isis
right to come into our great city of new
york which happens to be in the united
states of america
right to terrorize us right with their
ideology that's based on scriptures
that don't go against the bible they do
go against the bible
they have a different ideology although
be it we have
freedom of religion in this country yes
so you may
worship any god that as you as you want
so i am not judging
one's religion or sect or not domination
dominatrix dominatrix right
but yesterday at 2 32 p.m a.m
of today right in the subways of our
great city
you know they attacked a bunch of
um elderly elderly people in the subways
now what this elderly group of people
were going to a volleyball
game they were going to in a volleyball
tournament right in brooklyn
right they were going from queens to
brooklyn right they were
this elderly volleyball team right
they're called the hazmatics
and they were fighting you know yeah i
mean the crutchers
crutches the crutches in the the final
senior citizen tournament volleyball
tournament championship
championships in brooklyn and they were
waiting for the subway
right and as you know at 2 30 two in the
morning
the subways they don't they're not as
active as often
right and they come in waves the subways
so in the window between you know i mean
stop and go between the two
junctions right to the people right
hiri right no i'm not done oh [ __ ] i'm
not done okay
a gang of al-qaeda assange
terrorists right they came in with their
masks
we had no idea what was going on we have
we also have the best police force
in the subways of new york right and
they patrol them
you know at every hour in every station
in every point
and we are salutes to them so we salute
them
all the seniors were raped they were
raped
they were bent over the benches down
there in the subways
in a line right yeah and these al-qaeda
isis people
right they bend each one of them over
they loop their dicks because as as you
know
american citizens and senior citizens
they have dry
orifices they're getting old right they
were raped
then murdered then left to rock
this morning at eight in the morning is
when they were found
oh god yes so hiri hirihiri god bless
america
we will get these perpetrators and
so long honestly yeah
pretty good i mean as your secretary of
defense
pretty good i'm impressed no the wars
that america has fought in
right we fought in world war ii the gulf
war no but what was the war right after
that after world war
ii yeah the korean war right yes
so correct it's not that far of a
stretch
what is it when i said world war ii and
i meant to say korean [ __ ]
they're pretty close next to it one of
them was a war involving the world
and the other one was us and the koreans
big big difference one of them had
hitler
remember that guy
dude i swear to god dude
if you were a teacher and you talked to
me like that you hear as i talked to you
as a teacher i would literally walk out
of the class okay how about this
we'll do a teaching exercise say mr
santino asked me hey what's the
difference between world war ii and the
korean war ask me as your teacher
mr santino oh yes robert yes um i was
wondering
what's the difference between um world
war
ii and korean war everybody laugh at
this stupid [ __ ] korean kid
get out of here during commercial
auditions they go all right say your
name
you go i'm bobby lee i'm 5'4
profiles and you do your profiles right
stand at the other side so i do it like
this is what i do this is so gross but i
go if they
say dude do your profile okay okay go
ahead and slate what
go ahead go ahead and slate what is it
oh say your name and then you're hiding
the camera uh
you know i make it seem like oh you you
goof around right
and then i was trying to make a joke
like i only do one profile because the
other ones you know
it's flat flat anyway i'll make a joke
my face is flat anyway i'm in the castle
yeah all right bobby so could you just
read the line the line of course is
right there and it just says this tastes
exactly like apple juice that my
grandmother used to make
go ahead uh can i improvise we'd rather
you not
this is mox and it's family yeah there's
a family so that tastes like the apple
juice my grandmother used to
uh this is the well bobby let us count
yeah
i don't wanna i'm getting panicked okay
i feel nervous right now
and go ahead yeah this is just like the
um cranberry juice my apple
used to make
you got the part that's exactly how i
would probably do it yeah you'd [ __ ] it
up i would [ __ ] it up on purpose
and then leave and then i'd get a call
back and then that's when
that would it can backfire yeah [ __ ]
that guy
i [ __ ] hate that guy so much no you
don't oh dude if kirk cameron was here
i would go he'd say hello and i would
look him right in the eyes and go
go [ __ ] yourself ladies and gentlemen
kirk cameron if he came in right i took
his deck
just the wrong way